foreign
how are you
hey Dave how are you doing better than
we deserve what's up yeah all right um
so I just had a quick question
um
so I'm thinking about buying a rental
property with my sister
um but she's made it very clear that she
doesn't want a a 15-year cheat we we're
kind of on a time limit
um because my my income of this year is
gonna be like not really that high and
so we're going to be going off on
my income of last year
um and so I was just wondering if it's
going to be a rental and if we're not
really going to be living in it
um and if you know we can potentially
sell it before the 30-year mark this
would be you have three reasons you
should not do this deal
number one you're broke you don't make
enough money to do the deal number two
uh you're you're going to be in a
partnership with someone you're already
in a disagreement with on how to
structure the deal that's Dom
Partnerships are dumb Partnerships with
family can be really bad idea and uh
number three you shouldn't buy rental
property with debt at all
we should pay cash for it
so um but you're kind of new to this
whole Ramsay thing so you didn't know
any I was going to say any of those
things but one of the things we use
around here is the only ship that won't
sales a partnership
because doing 30 years of financial
coaching uh you know what I see a lot
people like you and your sister in my
office both of you pissed off
yeah I can see it yeah because it didn't
because the partnership didn't work yeah
I would tell her I love you enough that
I'm not gonna do this yeah or I'm I'm
out it's not gonna work for me well I
mean you're not making as much money
tells me that you're not you know you're
not making good money you don't need to
be getting in the rental property and
you're financing it and you want to do a
15 because you got at least that much of
a glimpse of the Ramsey stuff uh and
she's like no I want to stay in debt
forever
Dave I just keep having this
conversation with folks about my age a
little bit younger a little bit older
who just keep living on Tick Tock and
they think that they are broke if they
don't have rental property they will
live in a two-bedroom apartment and try
to buy a rental house with a 30 or 40
year note it's Madness yeah it's
heartbreaking what it is it's the it's a
get rich quick syndrome and it's uh this
idea that you know I I'm going to invest
in property uh because that's going to
make me wealthy and the truth is that
real estate does not make broke people
wealthy it makes them broker that's why
they call them brokers and so it's you
know it's just when you're broke real
estate is is a game that you play when
you have cash lots of it because you
need to play the long ball with real
estate and when you get up against the
edge and the Sparks start flying because
there's friction because there's no
margin that's when you're gonna lose
your butt in real estate so I started
with nothing I had four million dollars
worth of real estate by the time I was
26 with a million dollar net worth I was
making 200 000 a year in eight in 1980
freaking threes
that's a lot of money back then I lost
it all because I was playing the same
stupid Buck games that you people are
watching on Tic Tac